[Music]
President Obama's in town
today and you're one of those guests who
you just made it here like two minutes
it took me about 17 days to get here
yeah
from from from Venice I just literally
parked the car with my son and I walked
straight on people have no idea when
Obama comes to town everything in this
town stops that's what it's like in
London when I get there
very it's crazy that's what it's like
when I go to Finland every day yeah I've
heard that I'm a god there yeah don't
mess with congratulations on the awards
by the way incredible yeah they were all
fake I think they were bowling trophies
one is the odd dog I'm very proud of
those fake Awards that was given yes
that I'm myself by I just mentioned you
finished up working on True Blood just
two weeks ago yep and the show is gonna
get the last ones gonna air in in August
yeah yeah formerly unemployed you're
unemployed I am unemployed and in really
enjoying it I've been down to the dole
office we call it the dole office you
went down to the unemployment off the
unemployment office really find on yeah
very happy incredible what's better the
dole in in England or unemployment you I
think you get more unemployment here
than you do in England it's about 40
pence for for two weeks right
yes forty pence is like 25 cents right
that's their way of basically saying go
and work yeah get a job which is okay
yeah well I think you should go back to
your country and live off that system
I'm sorry but USA USA you know it's
important that you say that you did
better than us in the World Cup anyway
well I don't know we did we did well
we're getting there in this country with
the world I have been saying for ages
that that might my daughter today wäôre
so here and I've been saying for ages
that the training is so much better than
in England really yeah they worked so
hard it's fantastic I just think I think
this World Cup made a huge difference I
think was a game changer because for the
first time I saw everybody watching
soccer yeah all of us talking about it
which hadn't happened before I think
kids that are 2 years old now I do love
watching you guys to talk about it well
that was a great play the way he kicked
it with his foot there
there there Oh they've stopped stop what
are they do it's a free kick they don't
have to pay for it and yeah that is
exactly there's a lot of I was watching
I'd be like look at that we run around
Wow they never stop yeah that they
really they really are go-getters those
guys never cut the commercials yeah so
then you don't know when you have to go
and make your coffee right yeah mostly
it's about urinating in our country and
then more coffee it was about True Blood
and True Blood known in part you guys
were not afraid to to bear a little skin
on the show and in the publicity for the
show you did a very well-known Rolling
Stone cover which I'll show right here
which was quite fasting and I'm
wondering how much how much did you have
to be talked into that cover how's it
work you show up and they say we'd done
about two hours shoot and very
conventional shoot it was really nice
and me and skarsgård is sitting there
eating our sandwiches thinking it's all
done and they and the photographer comes
over and he says this is my hundredth
cover that I've ever done for Rolling
Stone and would you consider doing
something a little bit different we've
been thinking you know it'd be really
good if and and we're all like you want
us to take our clothes off don't you and
you know buy and he's like yes but you
know it's gonna be really tasteful and
like ten seconds later I mean skarsgård
trousers around the end cause my wife's
like can you undo the thing darling you
know right and you didn't take a lot of
convincing we didn't and and my little
makeup artists like we're just given
like giant paint brushes and in Brit and
they were just like splattering you know
it was like that scene in Zoolander
where the boys throwing blood at each
other or fake blood I hope I'm curious
you know you played a vampire all these
years and I remembered you mentioned me
once it was part of your contract that
you needed to stay out of the Sun and
stay pale that's right which is not part
of my contract it just works out that
but you'd be great and I'll show them
well yeah thanks for saying that now
that you're going yeah yeah no one ever
mentioned that before I was done you
would have been good
right now are you gonna go out and like
really start getting a tan
yeah I'm allowed to do that I can
actually spend some time on the beach
and but the problem is of course that
I've got a bit for farmers ten like me
and my boy play golf and we've got like
this ridiculous thing so we've just been
on this holiday going down the river on
tubes and stuff and you know just being
out in the Sun and it's so ridiculous my
thing so I've been putting like factor
70 up to here
and then burning right the rest come on
come and get me and you know that goes
much higher than 70 I happen to know
that I'm working on a 120 that I might
show up at then yeah that's for your own
range of product it fires light back at
the Sun
you